donald trump está dispuesto a retomar su
campaña electoral una semana después de
ser ingresado por kobe 19 anunció que
presidirá un evento al aire libre en la
casa blanca el sábado y realizará un
acto multitudinario en florida este
lunes tan solo dos semanas después de un
evento en el rose garden para nominar a
la jueza amy cón y barrett que terminó
con un alto número de contagiados estar
en sanford florida este lunes para un
gran rally mientras tanto joe biden
continuó con su campaña intentando
captar el voto latino en las vegas son
casi el 20 por ciento de la población de
eeuu 24 de cada 100 niños de la escuela
primaria son latinos no estoy tratando
de ser correcto con ustedes pero son el
futuro del país este viernes la polémica
entre trump y los demócratas aumentó la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi anunció un
proyecto de ley amparado en la enmienda
25 que pretende evaluar la aptitud
física y mental de futuros presidentes
estadounidenses a través de un grupo de
expertos que podrían destituir al
presidente si fuera necesario
esto no es sobre el presidente trump él
se enfrentará al juicio
pero su caso muestra la necesidad de que
creemos un proceso para los futuros
presidentes a lo largo de la historia de
eeuu a pesar de que supuestamente esta
ley no está pensada para echar a donald
trump el mandatario reaccionó en twitter
llamando loca a pelosi esta situación se
suma a la paralización de las
negociaciones para aprobar un paquete de
estímulo económico contra la crisis
provocada por el 19 de donald trump ya
amenazó con no sacar adelante hasta
después de las elecciones a pesar de las
críticas